[Music]
[Music]
is riding shotgun with james corden on
the latest carpool karaoke and all we
gotta say is it's about damn time damn
this is a big deal yes it is lizzo the
two kick off the carpool with one of her
first hit singles
check my nails baby how you feeling
this is so cool
it is like people
know my music well enough that i can do
this this is so cool but they're all
banners that's the incredible thing
that's what i do
her music is kind of made for carpool
karaoke now not only is lizzo known for
her bangers she's also an impressive
flutist i've been playing the flu
forever so at one point james surprises
her with the instrument and she shows
off her skills hearing her play the
flute
dancing everything i mean it was just
it was wonderful it was just wonderful
being
in her company for for a couple of hours
all right
i got a flute
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god
yeah
now is this right you you you called
your flute
sasha fierce after beyonce's alter ego
sasha flute oh sasha flew her name is
sasha f-l-o-o-t and that nickname is
fitting because lizzo then opens up to
james about how much queen bee has
impacted her life when i
dropped out of college and i was really
depressed
i listened to b-day
on repeat and i would just sing b-day
all the time and i was like i'm gonna be
a singer i'm gonna be a singer the way
she makes people feel is how i wanna
make people feel with music
like i've she's been my north star after
that james totally tricks her into
thinking he has beyonce's number should
we call her
don't [ __ ] with me should we go do you
have the numbers should we call up
if you are gonna call beyonce
do you shall we call her don't scare me
no should we call it yeah yeah
oh are you joking there's no way i've
got a phone number
i almost got me you [ __ ] yeah lizzo
didn't hold that one against him because
she then teaches james how to do the
viral about damn time tick-tock
choreography after the pair pulls over
lizzo brings in a couple dozen backup
dancers including jaden gomez the
creator who came up with the dance they
then have a full-on flash mob for their
video man a woman to pump me up feeling
fussy walking in my ballistics he's
trying to bring out the fabulous cause
i'll give a [ __ ] wait wait so much
[Music]
that's how i feel right now
there we go it's always scary all right
i think we got it it's amazing for us to
be
doing a carpool going into the summer
with the artist who absolutely seems to
have the song of the summer so it was
just perfect it was glorious then back
in the car lizzo and james cap off the
carpool with a little truth hurts
[Music]
more
fresh